there is no denying the scent of fear
that gripped a city still stunned by the
previous night's events this was the
reaction when a man was arrested in an
unrelated incident at the Arndale
shopping center in the heart of
Manchester we asked for the comfort that
comes from your spirit but no panic
could drown out the sound of hope I
meant the sound of defiance they
couldn't get to the cathedral it ended
up in a police exclusion zone so they
held the lunchtime service on the street
according to its newly elected mayor
charity not terror would come to define
the city's response I want to thank the
people of Manchester even in the minutes
after the attack they opened their doors
to strangers and drove them away from
danger
they gave the best possible immediate
response to those who seek to divide us
and it will be that spirit of Manchester
that will prevail and hold us together
Manchester has stared terrorism in the
face before 21 years ago the IRA
detonated a truck bomb not far from the
arena
attack the postbox here in cross street
is one of the very few structures to
have survived the blast intact and it
became a symbol of Manchester's
resilience in the face of terror a
spirit that has risen again across the
road Masoud at bars I decided to open up
when shop shutters around his cafe
remained firmly closed we had to support
our community
and give them your share instead
Manchester is not a place for their
terrorist activities aDNA today we're
only here for giving free food and
breaks out and help the old girls that
are stranded here
hundreds of Mancunian offered up their
spare rooms in the attacks immediate
aftermath we could see people help us on
the form we thought well the it's late
now trains have been canceled so I
decided to put on Facebook post about
offering our flat for a room for sofas
and for space for people to stay at they
needed it a fundraising page raised
hundreds of thousands of pounds in a
matter of hours and the city's largest
private taxi firm suspended normal
service 200 cabs rallying to provide
free lifts to anyone who needed them as
people for Manchester would you is at
times of crisis everybody needs to get
together and we need to show these
people that at the end of day that we
can't be broken wheel as one solidarity
in such circumstances reaches far beyond
words it has been in its practical
response that the city has expressed its
love in the face of evil Mike McCarthy
Sky News Manchester